um how well I want to talk about because
I don't feel like you get enough credit
in terms of your ear for Talent on the
music side
um a girl like keilani somebody who was
signed with you initially her was signed
when she was 11. yeah to you to
incredible yeah
um you have like a now she went in
Oscars and Grammys and stuff shouts out
the young Gabby out there yeah how like
for you like
you get enough credit man when it comes
to the music because I feel like I
think I feel like people obviously think
listen you've put out some dope records
but I also feel like people don't really
take you serious as an as an artist
never tried to push it well also because
I feel like we just see you as doing so
many other things and like I came up in
a time where you couldn't do more than
one thing right so I had to pick and
choose so I chose you know you know
comedy and yeah Gigolo movies and
but so you couldn't do both when I was
young right but what's dope is that I I
was a DJ and a producer like all through
high school so I didn't really I never
wanted to be in front of the camera so
throughout my career I've written and
produced records that there I got
platinum records all day long but it's
just like I never was like this is me
looking and paying attention to me even
when it came to the Artistry stuff I
never was really on that so what I've
done now just because obviously the
spotlight is hot I I created a new show
for BT uh called future Superstars and
it's a tour as well so I saw you just
were on tour with uh Simba 24K so yeah
so the fact that now the television show
will show that Journey they would show
you know me as a music man and show me
in the space of talent Discovery or show
me me as a producer and all of that type
of stuff so I'm excited about that that
wave of my career because I had it has I
I haven't talked about it it has been
the afterthought a lot of times even
though I've been doing you know I make
all the music on wild and out you know
what I mean like I I it's a I'm a
musician's musician so that's where like
the fact that you know I could play
drums piano guitar all of that stuff
I've never really been like oh look how
well I rhymed these words together shout
out to everybody who does that but that
was never like my main focus because I
was more about creating movements and
creating opportunities so uh I'm glad
now that I get the opportunity to kind
of take that side of my career seriously
when you have like someone like her you
sign her as a kid sign her as a kid
um or Kaylani was she signed you before
she was 18 yeah yeah they were she was
right before she finished high school
what was the name of the group that went
on tour with tech nine uh psych ward
druggies the kid passed away who was in
there yeah Ryan Bowers rest his soul man
that was my man
but do you like like you let them out of
their deals did the deals run their
course I'm not even one of them dudes
like I'm like everybody else around me
wants me to be one of those dudes like
take the credit sign on me you put your
logo on it I'm like look give me the
credit when you want to give me the
credit like other than that it's cool
like I'm a handshake type of person I
don't want nothing from you uh except to
see you win so that's a rare thing in
this game but it's like I always tell
artists that I rock with look I'm Gonna
Be Rich whether you make it or not like
so I don't need like those ideas is like
I don't need anything from you like I'm
just gonna help you out so all I want to
do let me help you I'll give you advice
and see how you run but you know
obviously a lot of people think that you
know I should I should be taking
percentages and doing all of that so
usually I only ask for you know ass back
for the money that I put in if you're if
you're stable enough to do that but I
don't even have I mean you know these
major labels still owe me owe me checks
for you know the artist that I kindly
just gave them so but I just I did that
because I wanted to see those artists
win and didn't want them to get into a
deal in debt so I can always step away
but you know those those big record
execs you know you know who you owe
they owe you some money absolutely for
I mean if if they look up the paperwork
but I mean I'm good with all those
people just based off of the but I
definitely like I said I never wanted
anything from them right like I always
wanted them to succeed in even their
Arrangements that we made with uh
various management and various uh record
labels I was like yo I'll be I'll step
back now that I know they're in good
hands you know I'm off to the next thing
because I really don't want anything
from anybody but when those major
systems who make hundreds of millions of
dollars off of these artists like yeah
here let me get my investment back yeah
yeah yeah at least give me the money
that I've spent to to bring them to you
so you know but again I ain't that that
small paper I ain't really counting was
there anyone who uh you almost signed
that it got right to the finish line but
for whatever reason yeah a couple people
like Becky G I remember Becky G early on
you know uh she was she was like a
little 14 year old girl rapping yeah uh
so many people uh
I mean because I used to run uh teen
Island at Def Jam LA Reid put me in
charge of all of the team acts and you
know obviously the the it was it was a
cool roster it was a group I created
called the school girls this artist
named Aaron Fresh who was super dope uh
and we had a arsenal of artists and I
was making I was putting them all in
Gabby was a part of that as well we put
them all in these Nickelodeon movies uh
that we were making in the first the the
star at the time the one that obviously
the the biggest act on teen Island he
just was bubbling off the internet was
this young kid named Justin Bieber
the rest is history really the whole
teen Island budget just folded and went
into beaver's career and it's the Justin
Bieber that we know to to this day so
was that prior to him linking with Usher
it was during the same time same time
same time that was like it was like I
said Tina he had he got the deal in the
building but as you you know you know
they upstreamed him quickly yeah yeah so
like uh I think I think the the
Nickelodeon movie that we put on was
Justin's first thing ever on television
so uh in the first movie and stuff that
he had ever did because before then he
was just this dope little kid from
YouTube that they were about to put out
a record and all that and so I was like
yo he about to go and then he he went oh
he went oh